funny that in a time when we are told
that we have to review american history
and we have to rethink american history
there's a simultaneous attempt to remove
all the iconography of the past in order
that we never have to discuss it ever
again yeah i really don't think that the
future is going to have a very tough
time figuring out why america fell
first of all just want to say
to all of my listeners that means have a
happy and sweet new year because the
last couple of days i was off thanks to
the jewish new year which is a time for
reflection it's a time for thought it's
a time for making new resolutions it's a
time for renewal in fact and
the good news is that
we did that in my community we spent
some time thinking about all those
things and then the bad news was i came
back and i read the news and i realized
that the united states is in an
apparently an irreversible state of
decline
that seems to be all the news that is
fit to print and the great indicator of
this
was the situation that has now arisen
over the removal of the robert e lee
statue in virginia
now here's the thing
i totally understand why people would
want the robert e lee statue removed in
richmond virginia i do i get it i
understand if you're a black american
and you look at a statue of robert ely
who presided over the army of the
confederacy which was an army that was
in favor of the remaining the the
continuation of slavery you look at that
statue and you say why exactly are
people paying homage to this man why
exactly would we do that isn't that a
vestige of american racism i get it i do
i also understand the people who are
descended from southerners who fought in
the civil war who look at lee and what
they see was a man who presided over the
the civil war yes but also presided over
reconstruction to the extent that he
didn't continue the guerrilla war right
this is a major issue at the time is
whether robert e lee was actually going
to continue to foment the civil war
after his surrender at appomattox and he
pledged that he would not do so and he
would use all his efforts to bring the
country back together there was a
feeling in the south that he was sort of
the the romantic figure of
gentlemanliness some of that image has
been obviously tarnished by historians
who have now come forth with new details
about his life
but lee was a very human figure in a lot
of variegated forms and what that means
that people view him in different ways
so i totally understand the argument to
remove
robert e lee's statute i get it
i think that there are people who make
the argument that robert e lee stash you
should come down for the same reason
that george washington or abraham
lincoln's statue should come down that's
idiotic
and that is a different argument and
herein lies the problem
and the problem is not the pure removal
of the robert e lee statue although my
view of this generally is with conolisa
rice's view of this which is that
statues generally ought to remain up
because they remind us of a past when
people were in fact held in high esteem
despite having really really bad views
and fighting for really bad things and
so that provides you a jumping off point
for discussion of these issues what was
going on in america in 1858 right why
did people think in 1890 was worthwhile
to build this statue of robert e lee's
gigantic 21-foot statue of robert e lee
right all of those things are good for
the discussion of the american body
politic in american history it's kind of
funny that in a time when we are told
that we have to review american history
and we have to rethink american history
there's a simultaneous attempt to remove
all the iconography of the past in order
that we never have to discuss it ever
again right that's that's kind of
bizarre
so my view is that the statue should
remain and we should discuss the statue
in all of its complexity and all of its
nuance
okay however that's really not my issue
here my issue is what we replace things
with what we replace american history
with what we replace that discussion
with and what we have decided to replace
the discussion of american history with
what we've decided to replace our own
history with
is a perverse simplified wokeness that
does spell the end of america in pretty
much all of its forms not the getting
rid of the robert e lee statue per se
but what we are replacing it with and
what i mean here is that there was a
time capsule that was buried under the
robert e lee statue in the base of the
statue we are now replacing it okay this
is the part that's kind of astonishing
and also
the imagery that was associated with the
removal of the robert e lee statue right
if you're going to remove the
iconography of the past it should be
done
in a sort of i would say solemn fashion
it should be done very seriously
instead the robert e lee statue was
removed to the wild celebration of a
crowd below as though they were toppling
a statue of saddam hussein or something
robert e lee does not preside over the
country nor did he ever preside over the
country per se right he was the general
of the confederacy the confederacy was
defeated between 1861 and 1865 and uh
you saw one of the people who was taking
this thing down had been tasked with
taking this down putting up the black
lives matter fist as this was taken down
now you can say that maybe the statue
should be taken down but replacing it
with the ideology of black lives matter
which is that america is invariably
racist not only conflicts with the
actual imagery which is
a black man taking down a statue of a
confederate general which does not be
speak the white supremacy of the united
states in 2021 but also black lives
matter is
is pushed and and based on a lie the lie
that black americans are
immutably
stricken by the american systems of
power that it's the same sort of
rationale as critical race theory black
lives matter and if you're a black
person in america you live with the boot
of america on your throat all day long
that obviously is not true i mean we're
literally taking down statues right now
right that offend people
but that sort of imagery is telling
what's even more telling is again the
time capsule so the time capsule to me
is the story not even the removal of the
statue the statue's a story but a much
bigger story and a more indicative story
is this time capsule removal because
then remove the time capsule right which
is generally you put vestiges of what
you think are the most important objects
of the day and you bury them
and then in a hundred years the cool
thing about a time capsule is you open
it up and you have all the artifacts
from 120 years ago 130 years ago and you
can see what was important to people at
the time
what we replaced the objects in the time
capsule with underneath the robert e lee
statue says everything about this future
archaeologists are going to have zero
problems whatsoever understanding the
decline in fall of the united states
they're going to look at this time
capsule and they're going to go up well
that was not a toughy that was not
difficult it's not going to be edward
gibbon writing a millennium later trying
to figure out exactly why rome declined
and fell and trying to suss out all of
the various rationales
here is the actual story behind the
story
so they got rid of the robert e lee
statue
and then
they took away
the artifacts that were inside this time
capsule that had been placed in the
pedestal of the monument on october 27
1887.
they said that the
objects in the old capsule were believed
to have ties to the confederacy ralph
northam the governor who also apparently
had ties to the confederacy considering
he was either wearing blackface or a kkk
outfit in his medical yearbook he says
this monument and its time capsule
reflected virginia in 1890 and it's time
to remove both so our public spaces
better reflect who we are as a people in
2021. now here we go
what exactly was in the new time capsule
right what what what did they decide
that they were going to place inside the
new time capsule
this is supposed to remember signify
what america is all about what is in the
artifact list now
okay so here's what they put in there
they put in there a black lives matter
sticker
which is again significant of a movement
that suggests that america is
irredeemably racist
they took down a robert e lee statue
because america's irredeemably racist so
you've got these stickers saying
america's irredeemably racist
they have writing a new history kente
cloth worn by the commissioners of the
congressionally chartered 400 years of
african american history commission and
ghanaian emissaries that participated in
the 400th commemoration of 1619.
right so we have we have a kente
clothing commemoration of the 1619
project which again is a
designation that america is rooted in
evil and can never be extricated from
that evil and all of its institutions
are shot through with that evil evil we
have a virginia is for lovers pride pin
and sticker
which is great so we have a pride pin
signifying our our love and and
celebration of alternative sexual
proclivities and behaviors
not not of the family no you not like
the signification of the family but like
the pride pen
we have also
the virginia ratify era equal rights
amendment sash and the equal rights
amendment 2020 pins
so that's very important right so we
have an equal rights amendment sash and
pins for a constitutional amendment that
is not actually adopted and that
suggests that there are no differences
between men and women in law
we have a first lady face mask submitted
by first lady pamela northam
so first so it's her own face mask that
goes in the time capsule it's important
future generations know that we were
insane and that we face masked
presumably until the end of the american
republic we have photos and flyers from
stop asian hate protests in may 2021 in
the virginia time capsule
now so far have you heard anything that
celebrates america like a single thing
in this time capsule that says that
america is good or that our fundamental
institutions are good
nope
zero things
none
the only thing that really has to do
with the institutions of virginia per se
is a photo of the virginia state police
at 14th street and
f street northwest in washington
helping washington metro police
department patrol the city for unrest
after the insurrection at the u.s
capitol on january 6th that's we have a
commemoration of january 6th
which is really important so people
understand that the real threats of the
united states which responds to drugs
who ran into the capital building
we have an expired vial of the covet 19
pfizer vaccine and the cdc vaccination
record card
so if you think that america
has always been rooted in a creed that
america has a civic religion and
typically that civic religion is
embodied by the declaration of
independence say the american flag apple
pie motherhood all of that
we've now replaced this with the pride
flag pin a kente cloth for 1619
the the pseudo-pagan
worship
of
scientific materialism via a 19 vaccine
vial and a face mask for the first lady
yeah i really don't think that the
future is going to have a very tough
time figuring out exactly
why um why america fell i feel like this
one's going to be real easy for us
and here's the thing
as america collapses within and america
collapses without
the story is that we are basically just
going to eat ourselves to death we're
now the plot of wally right the best
hope for the united states according to
the democrats and according to joe biden
is that as we rip ourselves apart as we
lose all centralizing principle as we
collapse on the foreign front as we do
all of those things at the very least
what we can do is park our asses in a
recliner and just eat
a bunch of fatty foods until we die
that's it and the government will pay
for all of that unless you're
unvaccinated in which case die on your
own but otherwise the government will
pay for all of these things
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content